حريه التعبير والصحافه هي المكسب الابرز
للثوره التونسيه
يطرح واقعها راهنا اسئله ومخاوف كثيره
منير العرفاوي صحفيه يجري تحقيق معها في
قضايا مرفوعه من قبل احد الوزراء على
خلفيه مقالات انتقدت اداءه الحكومي تقول
انها تتعرض للتضييق من قبل السلطات واصبحت
ضحيه لمرسوم رئاسيا يقمع الحريات انا جزء
من الجسم الصحفي وهذا الجسم الصحفي اليوم
اللي هو حامل للواء حريه الراي والتعبير
واللي نعرفو الصحافه هي خيمه الراي
والتعبير فمه هو مستهدف بشكل مباشر من
السلطه وما الشيكايات المتتاليه الا نوع
من انواع هذا التنكيل وهذه الطفيقات التي
تمارس ضد كل الصحافيين دون استثناء بشكل
دوري وتزامنا مع اليوم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه تعرض نقابه الصحفيين تقرير
الحريات السنوي
كل هذا العام دق ناقوس الخطر وخلص الى
جمله من الاستنتاجات لعل ابرزها ان غالب
الانتهاكات مرتبطه مباشره بالاجراءات
الاستثنائيه التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس سعيد
وان الوضع في قطاع الاعلام
يتفاقم يوما بعد اخر تقريبا كانت
الانتهاكات او اغلبها خلينا نقول
مرتبطه ارتباط مباشر
بالاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي تم اعلانها
في 25 جويليه 2021
وكيف ساهمت هذه الاجراءات في توفير الغطاء
السياسي
للانتهاكات لطالما عبرت السلطات التونسيه
وفي مقدمتها الرئيس قيس سعيد عن تمسكها
بحريه التعبير سعيد الذي استنكر ورفض في
اكثر من مناسبه الانتقادات الموجهه اليه
والى المراسيم الرئاسيه التي اصدرها حريه
التعبير تقتضي حريه الفكر للاسف هناك
الاشخاص لا فكره لهم
وبطبيعه الحال حريه التعبير التي يتحدثون
عنها يتمتعون بها بالرغم من انهم يعيشون
في غيبوبه فكريه
تعيش الصحافه تونسيه في هذه المده تحديات
لم تشهدها من قبل
ومثلث السلطه التنفيذيه وفق منتقدها حجر
عثره امام تطور قطاع الاعلام اتهامات نظام
الرئيس في خانه تشويه ما يقول انه مسار
اصلاحي ضد الفساد لا تراجع عنه
الجزيره تونس